shocking new video shows the lawlessness
of democrat cities colliding with Joe
Biden's open borders Insanity two NYPD
police officers getting outnumbered and
savagely beaten by a large group of
illegal immigrants near Times Square
those cops were just trying to break up
a disorderly crowd outside a shelter
trying to arrest one of the illegals and
that's when the mob attacked one of the
thugs kicking an officer in the face
while he's on the ground he suffered a
cut to his face and the other officer
was injured five of those violent
suspects were arrested by police later
that same night charged with assaulting
a police officer but four of them
already back on the street released
without bail and get this they were only
in custody for three
hours and we're getting new video of
that fifth migrant in court today one
NYPD Chief says all of those cop beating
migrants should be locked
up reprehensible
cowards you have eight
people attacking on a lieutenant and a
cop the four that arrested should be
sitting in reichers right now on
bail should be indicted this week and
taken off our
streets you want to know why our cops
are getting
assaulted there's no consequences and we
must change this even New York Democrat
Governor Kathy h outraged and she's
floating the
dword why is it okay that they are left
out on bail I'm not satisfied with that
at all these are law enforcement
officers who should never under any sub
circumstances be subjected to physical
assault those individuals be
deported I think that's absolutely
something that should be looked at I
mean if someone commits a crime against
a police officer in the state of New
York um and they're not you know they've
not processed that they're not here
legally definitely worth checking into
okay okay so they're going to Greg check
into what an ass number one does she
even like this happens to Citizens all
the time right and now now she's like
shocked that it happened to Cops look
the Democratic party needs to change its
name to the BPP the breaking point party
because in every facet of society now we
are at its Breaking Point whether it is
crime and and immigration which is now
meeting M right there on the street
education you know division foreign
policy every place there's unfettered
progressivism you end up with chaos and
that is a microcosm of chaos you have
order represented by the police and you
have chaos represented by thugs now if
you point out this situation you're
talking about a policy what is wrong
with the policy but the moment you talk
about this the left will say you're
talking about people this is what they
do with with trans rights this is what
they do with everything it's like but
they always twist it so that you're
referring to the people but immigrants
are wonderful we're not arguing that
right we're addressing what's wrong with
a policy and it's one that progressives
create without ever factoring the
consequences which is what the what what
the uh the the police officer just said
they never factor in the consequences so
then you end up with incentivizing
criminals to do whatever they want which
is what they're doing and another
problem with Democrats Jessica they're
always Upstream from the mistakes they
Cause right all of their blunders are
felt Downstream like in Time Square by a
cop or maybe it's a pedestrian or
someone on the subway you for some
reason liberal leaders can afford such
mistakes because the consequences never
get near them so you have a governor
basically faking like she cares but she
doesn't because if she cared she would
have done something about the crime in
the city a long time ago and it's a
sanctuary City Dana so there's a good
chance they'll never be deported but
also don't you think that those three
that are out already they're already
back in shelters that you're paying for
right and that's pretty
gross what better sentence that sums up
the Biden Administration than this one
illegal immigrant mob beats up officers
released immediate without
bail I I like that's in one sentence you
got it right there you don't even need
to pay 30 seconds for a commercial for
it Paul marrow the Fox News contributor
former NYPD officer said today that
there's indication he's heard from
sources there in the police off uh
police force that there's organized
pickpocketing Happening by Venezuelan
gangs what do we know that Biden did he
said okay if you're Venezuelan you can
come because we feel bad for you because
things are terrible things are things
are terrible there right so you get to
come and you get to live here and you
and you get to do this to our people and
the other thing that happened in New
York City you've got a mayor who tried
to override a City Council vote that's
going to make officers take a note
anytime he comes into contact with a
citizen you have to go back and file a
paperwork in triplicate form and he the
mayor tried to overwrite it we had a mom
on Newsroom this morning who's
devastated by it she tried to fight for
the mayor and say my daughter was killed
last year they never would have found
her murderer if cops had to do this
please don't do this and they overrode
the mayor's veto not by just a little
bit 42 to n so the city is I think at a
Breaking Point in particular and we as
Hammer told me today was like we have
too much to lose here well Democrats
have been voting for this and this is
what you get
Jessica you're up great um happy to be
here
so it's a terrible situation there
there's no defense of it and it's not
really about necessarily that this is a
s uary City because there are migrants
are being busted to non Sanctuary cities
and I think it really does come down to
Kathy hokel executing that idea that if
you are a migrant and you are here
illegally that you are deported right
away that you have harer penalties for
doing something like this because you're
here out of the good graces of our heart
and we've been talking about that
consistently you know with migrants that
are on the street pushing people out of
hotels pushing people out of schools
we're going to talk about that as well
um out of rec centers closing those down
because they have to move migrant
families into them I think there should
be harsher penalties for that and I went
back and looked at the legislative
history of Kate's law remember the law
that was created for Kate Stein Lee of
the 32-year-old woman in San Francisco
who was murdered by an undocumented man
who I think had been deported six times
or something like that and it passed the
house in 2017 it had 24 Democrats that
voted for it um and it still needs to
get through the Senate and Ted Cruz
reintroduced it again last last year I
think that this is a moment where people
are feeling
this so deeply that something like that
could get passed and I think that that
would be a step in the right direction
but obviously the federal government
needs to do better in terms of making
sure that people like that are not here
judge Janine Pio you know it's
interesting uh Greg when you talk about
policy versus people uh I've always and
that's certainly legitimate I've always
talked about people I talk about the
fact that we don't get angry enough when
people are hurt look these illegals came
here illegally they were not invited
here uh and they don't belong in Rikers
they belong back in Venezuela if indeed
they are Venezuelans okay they need to
be deported immediately because we don't
want people like that in our country we
don't want people like that who
literally take down the establishment
Law and Order who violently attack a
police officer get him to the ground and
kick him in the face kick him in the
head and then they join each other and
you know the amazing thing is these
people want Asylum I don't believe
they're entitled to Asylum they say they
come here because they'll be persecuted
in their own country chances are they
deserve to be persecuted in their own
country because I'm going to make a bet
that this isn't the first time they' try
to take down a police officer or someone
in authority and yet they're going to
want us to give them Asylum from their
country they need to go back to their
country now aside from the fact that
this is free advertising for the cartels
and this has been on all day long it's
proof to the world that we don't even
have the Dignity of Defending ourselves
in our own system and blacks in this
country are taking a second seat and I
don't like it they're on the losing end
of the stick whether they're in Chicago
in Boston or in New York City whether
they're they're being moved out of
school gyms or moved out of uh hotels or
any where else illegals are taking
priority over the blacks in this country
and it's hard I mean if you want to give
a sport center in Boston to illegals as
opposed to minority kids who deserve it
and who are American citizens then that
tells me that you are all in for people
coming here who don't even want to swear
allegiance to this country I used to
swear those people in 300 a month they
used to come in with American flags they
love this country it was the happiest
day of their lives they couldn't wait to
take a picture they knew more American
history than I did do you think these
people deserve to be
Americans I don't I don't either nope
and Joe Biden could have prevented this
but he didn't hi everyone I'm Brian
kilme I want you to do me a favor I want
you to click to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page this is the only way
that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now